[Arabic recitation]
early he was Allah
and my bad
continuing in the summary
finishing up the topic of el is
a little half of
[Silence]
foreign
yakulu
[Silence]
alum
a
is
[Silence]
foreign
the night journey and the Ascension of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he basically mentions here
that it has been mentioned
that is
two companions
held the opinion that is
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam soul for his soul alone not his
body as well
now is pointing out a couple of things
and one of the things that he's pointing
out here is
the scholars have differed
albeit very slightly
on whether or not his body was taken
on the night journey and Ascension
or was it just his soul that was taken
none of them
mentioned that it was a vision that he
saw while he was asleep and that's
something that's very clear right
because
the people of Islam and the non-muslims
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
enemies and his and his supporters
would not have a big problem accepting
that he saw this in a dream I mean if he
said I saw in a dream that I was taken
and one night to from you know A month's
journey and then I ascended into the
heavens and I saw these prophets and so
forth that's not something that is out
of the realm of possibility we all agree
that people can see many things that are
physically impossible
that we can see these things made
possible in our and our dreams it's not
a problem
but the the vehement rejection
of
the disbelievers of quraish of this
account of Islam
articulate to us that
this was something that happened to him
physically was it with his body and his
soul together or was it just his soul
the majority of the scholarship of Islam
say that it was his body and his soul
together
and there are evidences of that
so for instance the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam mentioned on that night
that his heart was removed and washed in
zemzem and and put back into his chest
and so forth this is something that we
know physically happened because he had
scarring from this event that NS related
to us he said that he would see when the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
have his
shirt off that there would be a scar
there from where the cut or the incision
was made
the point is is that none of the
companions were of the view that this
was something that was in a dream this
was not a dream this is something that
actually happened
now the nature of this happening was it
physical or merely spiritual
the majority of the scholarship of Islam
and the companions all agree that this
was something that was a physical and
spiritual so both his body and his soul
and this is not something that
we should try to rationalize because
these are Miracles and the nature of
miraculous things miraculous events is
that they
go against known
physical limitations right
so the nature of a miracle isn't that we
don't know how it happens
the nature of a miracle is that we know
it cannot happen except
that this thing could not be done except
for the one who made those laws of
nature is the one who can break those
laws of nature this is the nature of a
miracle in its essence
and so
it's important for us to understand that
the prophets and Messengers they have a
very different type of existence
in that time between
death and Resurrection
prophets and Messengers their souls
experience a different kind of life
then the rest of humanity
does in this after death between death
and Resurrection
he mentions that's an example of this is
that we see
that the prophet mentions to us that he
passed by Muse
praying in his grave you saw that and
then he ascended into the heavens and he
found Musa there in the sixth heaven and
then he came back down and Led Led the
prophets in
right it doesn't mean that Musa was in
his grave and then after he passed him
he took him up into the heavens and then
after that he brought him back down
and then after that took him back to his
grave it's not it doesn't mean that it
means that the prophets and Messengers
their souls exist in a plane of
existence and reality than the rest of
us during
after our death
so just
gives us an example he says and this is
something that is beyond what we really
can grasp it's kind of Beyond something
that we're able to
understand fully how it works
but you know just as the sun is in the
same place
but many different people will see the
sun
from different angles and different
places at the same time
the soul is more of a mystery to us than
that so it's important for us to
understand the difference between
saying it was a spiritual journey
and saying it was a vision in his sleep
all of the companions agree that this is
not something that
he saw in a dream in his sleep this is
something that actually happened
even Abdul bar
ahima Allah one of the great Scholars of
the fifth century he mentions that
this incident
happened
about
14 months before Hijra
so that would place it at roughly the
11th between the 11th and 12th year
after prophethood
and about a a year and change before
Hijra
foreign
[Silence]
Torah
whatever
[Silence]
fisheria
foreign
[Silence]
literature
foreign
[Silence]
alcohol will be Anna
Atkins
[Silence]
foreign
Rojas
[Silence]
foreign
s another thing is that there's a number
of opinions with regards to
if
is the the night Journey happened on the
same night
and did it happen while he was awake or
asleep
and did it happen more once and the
answer is that
it happened
physically literally happened
and that was with his and his soul
together
and that is it it didn't happen more
than once
and any other opinion
outside of what we've just mentioned is
a weak opinion and that's important for
for us to understand an important thing
for us to understand
that just because there's a difference
of opinion
doesn't mean
that
all of those opinions are Justified
equally and it doesn't mean that all of
those opinions
are equal in strength
right
what do I mean by that
there are
times a lot of times
most of the time
most of the elements of Islam are agreed
upon amongst all the scholars
and if you go to open a book of filk for
instance
you're going to find
a number of opinions on one issue
correct is common
why is it that it seems everything
is different upon amongst the scholars
the answer is number one
the scholars write books to deal with
those differences
they don't write books
usually
listing all of the things that are
agreed upon and are a matter of
consensus amongst the scholarship of
Islam
usually a scholar who writes a book on
filth jurisputin's writes that book in
order to address
those differences of opinion and come to
some kind of solution and to come to a
resolution
right so when you open that book you're
opening that book
presuming that he's going to mention
everything that's agreed upon which is
usually not the case usually Scholars
when they write books
they write those books in order to deal
with the issues that have been differed
upon amongst amongst them not agreed
upon
second of all just because the
doesn't mean that all of those opinions
are equal in strength
and doesn't mean that all of them are
equally valid and all of them are
equally
acceptable that's not the case
human beings say many different things
we're talking about scholarship that has
extended almost 1500 years 1 500 years
in an Empire that is much larger than
other Empires seen
in history
with Scholars from different places
unable to communicate with one another
coming to different conclusions
it doesn't mean that everything that a
scholar says is equally as valid as
everything else doesn't mean that this
is why we have the Quran we have the
Sunnah we have the Quran we have the
Sunnah and what the Quran is usually
clear very clear
not an issue that is open
however
when there are references of opinion
that's when we have to look to the
scholars so they can
harmonized
differences for us and make sense
these things
this is an important point because
oftentimes
will
write even articles or you may read in
some books or even the way that some
teachers teach
you get the idea the impression that
as long as a scholar said it it's okay
that's not the case
we have the Quran we have the Sunnah and
most things that are expected from us
are very clear right
however there are instances where
Scholars differ
and all of those opinions are not equal
in validity
some of those opinions are more valid
than others some are more clear than
others
and so
there are instances where the difference
of opinion is very strong is very very
strong and they use very strong
evidences and at that point it's very
fine-tuning to be able to come to a
conclusion
that's something that belongs to that
falls in the lap of our scholarship they
have to choose for that what what if it
is relevant what if it applies to us and
put that to practice for us we can't
make that decision our own because that
is something that takes special
specialization
however
there is a difference of opinion
doesn't mean that
the correct opinion becomes any weaker
that's an issue that a lot of people
seem to misunderstand so a good example
of this
is reciting
right
so we have
narrations many narrations in which
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
clearly says
is not resided is valid
a person who prays without reciting had
their prayers invalid right many
narrations that
those narrations are agreed upon as
being authentic
those narrations are in the most
authentic books of narration
Muslim all of the six books of Hadith
that's a clear narration if it's clear
what you're supposed to do what are you
supposed to read that's very clear it's
obvious right it doesn't take
scholarship to know that
but then we have other narrations or I'm
sorry we have certain opinions and
certain schools of thought
that say
actually reciting
is something that's preferred but you
don't have to your prayer is still valid
if you don't recite Surah Fatiha now
that statement
does it make the words of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam any weaker
the answer is no
if the messenger says
no prayer is accepted without reciting
and then a scholar comes later on and
says
you can pray without reciting and your
prayer is acceptable does that change
the words of the Prophet it doesn't
change it does it make those words any
less any less authentic no does it make
those words any less authoritative no
it's the same Authority it says
so what I'm trying to get at here is not
all opinions are the same
so now just with that issue
we have
the majority of scholarship
they say reciting in prayer is a pillar
of Salah you have to if you don't do it
on purpose the ability to do so your
prayer is invalid that's stupid then we
have another minority who say you don't
have to it's preferable but you don't
have to
I just gave you the two opinions are
those two opinions equal now
they're not equal
isn't one of those two opinions stronger
than the other stronger because
the opinion the first opinion is backed
by clear narrations clear and explicit
authentic narrations that say that
where the other opinion is not so clear
so just because a difference of opinion
happens doesn't mean that that makes all
opinions the same and we just basically
step back and say well the issue is not
clear so do whatever you'd it's not
what that means
and just because there's a difference of
an opinion
does not mean
that you can choose whatever of those
opinions you better
we choose the opinion that we follow
based on a number of factors either
there's a clear verse from the Quran a
clear narration of Faith there is a
consensus
Etc as for why
conflicting opinions come up
we're talking about
over a thousand years worth of
scholarship of millions of Scholars who
have said different things
it's possible that they didn't know
operations it's possible that that
happened before the narrations even
reached that in that region there's a
reason why these opinions happen
right
but the point that I'm trying to make is
that
sometimes we kind of fall into this
false
belief that
somehow
if there's a difference of opinion it
means that it's not clear and you can
basically do whatever you no that's
not the case the Quran is clear
the sun now is clear and what's expected
of us is clear
it's not it's not something that's
usually
overly complex to where the the average
person wouldn't understand it
it's becoming more and more complex to
understand because you know
most of us are living in such a
radically different time and place that
understanding the Quran and Sunnah as
they were meant to be as they were
revealed at the beginning is becoming
more and more difficult
however
just because there's a difference of
opinion
does not mean
that all of those opinions are equal
does not mean that one of those opinions
is not the right opinion does not mean
that
all of those opinions are the same does
not mean that you can choose whichever
one you best whatever one fits your
particular agenda best that's the one
that you choose that's not how things
work right
so
you know there there are a lot of
examples for this
and it's important that we understand
that when it comes down to issues of is
this opinion strong or weak who tells us
that the scholars same ones who
mentioned to us that there's a
difference of opinion the same ones that
are supposed to choose for us
there is a limit to what the average
person can do not every person can make
a decision
these are decisions that Allah
has placed
to the behest of the scholars this is
their responsibility they're the ones
who transmit to us
the texts of the Quran in Sunnah and
they are the ones who as well explain to
us and tell us how to put these things
into action
a good example of this is an example
given to us by IBN Al qaim himself the
author of
he gives us a good example
he says how what is the relationship
between
the Quran and the Sunnah
and the words of the scholars for
instance if I said to you
how many daily prayers are there
five daily prayers right
do I have to double check and make sure
that the scholar said that for that to
be the case
it's clear right what about
do I need a scholar to tell me that Zina
is Haram
it's clear it's in the Quran it's very
clear and not only is it in the Quran
it's in the
institutional memory and psyche of of
Islam
it's passed down one generation after
the other until it reaches us these are
things that don't change
for example
if we were to say that murder is Haram
right that's clear
bread is
these are things that I don't need a
scholar to tell me because as a Muslim
we already know these things
now
where do the words of the scholars come
in
gives an example he says
let's say a person can see the
cabinet they can see the Cabo with their
eye
right
do they need to look at the stars and
the position of the sun in order to
decide which direction the Kaaba is
in that case
oh they can see it it's right there they
don't need the sun and the stars to tell
them the direction of the Kaaba they
don't need a compass
do I need a compass to tell me which way
the Kaaba is if I can see it I don't
need a compass at that point right
when do I need the compass I need the
compass when I can't see the cabba
I can't see it
it's unclear which direction it is now I
need a compass to lead me to it
and this is the the relationship shared
between the words of the scholars and
the words of Allah and his messenger
the in this analogy the Kaaba is like
the Quran and Sunnah when it's clear and
you can see it right there's no two ways
about it
you don't need the compass to tell you
however
if we cannot see it with our naked eye
the Quran and Sunnah somehow we're not
it's not clear to us exactly what is
expected then we look to our Compass we
look to the words of the scholars to
explain that to us to point us in the
right direction
and if we look at it in this way
we will not
start to see all opinions as being
the same all opinions are not the same
there are wrong opinions
and there are right opinions
and just because a scholar said it
doesn't mean that it's necessarily
factual that is the exception
the norm is when a scholar speaks he's
correct otherwise he's not a scholar
right
however that is the exception
when a scholar makes a mistake it
happens we need to look at what the
majority of scholarships say we need to
have our current Scholars look at this
and point us in the right direction
come on